les premiers pas de l'euro dans la vie
quotidienne des français avec dès ce
matin dans quelques grandes surfaces la
possibilité de payer ses achats par
chèque ou par carte bleue
une initiative à la fois pédagogique et
pratique qui ne soulèvent pas encore l'
enthousiasme chez la plupart des
commerçants
jean-paul chapelle jeanne grégoire c'est
là où le consommateur dit madame
mademoiselle peut-être j'aimerais payés
en euros premiers paiements en euros par
carte bancaire dans cet hypermarché près
de paris michel edouard leclerc a déjà
réactualisé 40000 pris avec le taux
officiel connu depuis 48 heures
l'épicier profite de l'occasion pour
faire sa publicité il ose même donné une
leçon de pédagogie au ministre de
l'économie tout le monde va savoir assez
vite qu'un smig ses 1000 euros khalid
défense et un euro vous voyez chacun va
se faire comme ça dominique strauss kahn
a parlé de la baguette à 0,66 doit
l'acheter à neuilly chez nous ça va être
à 0,30 bon si le patron du magasin paye
aujourd'hui en euros ses propres clients
eux préfèrent encore la monnaie
nationale
tant que c'est pas du mont et courants
pas d'intérêt dans l'immédiat mais dans
trois ans une obligation
en france cinq cent soixante mille
commerçants sont équipés d'un terminal
de paiement électronique et pour la
moitié d'entre eux cette machine est
déjà compatible avec l'euro on va taper
comme d'habitude je vais on va taper au
franc et l'expression du ticket souvent
en français et en euros
par conséquent il n'y a pas de
modifications pour livres jouets les pas
programmé pour prendre le groupe
elle est programmée seulement pour
prendre les francs dans leur grande
majorité les commerçants n'ont encore
fait aucune démarche au groupement des
cartes bancaires
dernier test ultime contrôle pour le
client le basculement en euros doit être
simple comme un jeu d'enfant y a pas
besoin de changer de carte les 30
millions de cartes bancaires aujourd'hui
en circulation sont tout à fait aptes à
fonctionner en euros y a pas besoin non
plus d'avoir un con
en euros vous ne touchez à rien vous
gardez votre compte et votre carte
encore faut-il que le commerçant
l'acceptent sinon les accros de l'euro
pourront tenter un autre paiement par
chèque mais dans ce cas il faut un
chéquier spéciale